-Mike Myers, welcome back.
We love having you on the show.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for being here.
-Lovely to be here.
-We have a lot of things
we have to get into
and talk about.
-Sure.
-But backstage, you just told me
something very interesting.
I know you were a big fan
of the queen.
-I was, in fact, yes.
-Yeah.
-I am Canadian, you see.
-Yes.
Can you tell everyone
what you told me --
you went to Buckingham Palace?
-I went to Buckingham Palace
with Steve Higgins.
That's right.
Not recently,
but a couple of years ago,
and a friend of mine arranged
for Steve and I to
watch the changing of the guard
from inside
Buckingham Palace's gates.
-Wow.
-We went through a rigorous
security, background check
and all this stuff.
Being of English -- My parents
are from Liverpool, England,
so it's like,
a huge, huge deal.
-Of course.
-And we got let in.
And then the band come out,
and they're playing
that, you know --
♪ Ba-da-da-da-da ♪
You know, all that --
[ Imitates fanfare ]
And I'm like,
"Oh, this is so amazing."
And then they break into
the "Austin Powers" theme.
[ Laughing ]
-And they started playing
"Soul Bossa Nova."
And it's like --
[ Sings "Soul Bossa Nova" ]
[ Band plays "Soul Bossa Nova" ]
There you go!
[ Applause ]
[ Singing along ] You know?
-I mean --
-And I just --
I couldn't believe it.
One of the guards walked by
holding a flag,
and they're not
supposed to talk.
He goes, "Oh, I bet you've heard
this song before, Mr. Myers."
And I'm like,
"Don't talk to me!"
-"You're not allowed to talk!"
-"Don't talk!"
"I'm Canadian,
I'm gonna get in trouble!"
-How cool is that?
That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-Speaking of Austin Powers,
though, we've talked about it on
the show a bunch of times.
Would you ever do another
Austin Powers?
Would you ever do
anther "Wayne's World"?
These are rumors that
I'm starting.
[ Applause ]
We don't have an applause sign!
They're doing that
because they love this!
-Aww.
-Would you do another
Austin Powers?
Do you have something
to announce?
-No, I don't have anything
to announce.
I -- I can neither confirm
nor deny the existence
or non-existence of
such a project.
-Yeah.
-Um, yeah.
I would love to do it.
Of course. It's fun.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What do you need?
How do we make this happen?
What would it be --
How can I --
What can we do?
A Dr. Evil spin-off?
-I just, you know, I have three
kids under the age of 11.
I've been super, super busy
being a dad.
-I know, but come on!
We want more! We want more
from you, Mike Myers!
-Alright.
-We need ya!
-I'll see what I can do,
Jimmy Fallon.
-Thank you very much.
-Very good.
-I want to hear about
"Amsterdam."
-Sure.
-We had Robert de Niro
on the show, but what a cast.
Margot Robbie, Christian Bale.
-No, it was like doing a movie
at Madame Tussaud's.
-[ Laughs ]
-I was so intimidated.
-Yeah.
-Chris Rock and I were just
watching the rest of the cast,
and we were like, "Oh, my God.
Actors are awesome,
aren't they?"
-No, please.
-They're just --
It was just
absolutely intimidating.
-How's David O'Russell?
-David O'Russell's a genius.
-He's one of the best directors.
-Oh, my God.
He's an American auteur.
It was one of the most creative,
fantastic experiences.
I was super sad when
it was over.
And it was just,
everybody pulled together.
It was an unbelievable --
-Did you talk much with
De Niro?
-I did, but I was too
intimidated, you know?
Because it's sort of like
being in a scene
with the Eiffel Tower, you know?
It's like, "Oh, my God.
Those are the molecules that
make up Robert de Niro."
-Yeah, he's the real deal.
-Holy crap.
And he was super lovely.
He's very introverted
and very, very nice,
and I just -- I didn't want to
take up any of his time.
So he'd be like,
"Do you live in New York?"
And I'd be like, "Yeah,
I live in New York.
I love it. Great."
We'd just sort of like --
Don't talk to him. Don't take up
any more of his time.
"Aren't you from Toronto?"
"I'm from Toronto.
I live in New York.
I love New York." Done.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like,
"Mike Myers is weird."
-"This guys' bizarre."
And I developed this laugh, too,
so he'd be like,
"On night shoots,
do you drink coffee?"
I'd go -- [Laughing],
"Yeah, I do."
[ Laughter ]
I don't have that laugh!
I've never had that laugh.
You kept doing it?
-Oh, my God.
[Laughing] "Yeah, you know.
It's great."
-"You like coffee?" [Giggling]
[Laughing throughout] "Yeah,
I love coffee, who doesn't?"
-[Laughing] "Milk, sometimes,
cream in the coffee, sugar."
-"Yeah, sometimes sugar."
[Laughing]
-You're like, "What am I doing?"
-What an idiot.
-Do you stay in character
when you're in that character?
-I've always done.
I've always stayed in character,
and now it's just superstition,
at this point.
And I thought, "is this weird?"
And then Christian Bale
also stays in character all day.
And because of
the improvisational nature
of the movie, I was never sure
when the day was done
and I could talk in
my normal accent again.
Neither did Christian Bale,
so I ran into him
in front of his trailer,
and he's English, right?
He's from Wales, but he has
an English accent,
but he's playing an American.
And I'm North American,
playing an English person,
and so he's sort of like,
[In character accent]
"Where ya from, mate?"
[In character accent] "Well,
actually, I'm from Toronto."
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, "Am I...?"
-What a brain workout!
-I'm like, "I'm not gonna break.
I'm not gonna break.
I'm committed."
-That's really fun.
-[As Christian Bale] "No, I'm
from a small town in Wales."
And I'm like, "Well, see, I'm
from the suburbs of Toronto.
[ Laughter ]
Terribly English.
-Hockey.
-I love hockey and maple syrup,
mountains and all that."
-Can we tell everyone
what "Amsterdam" is about?
It's a comedic thriller.
-It is.
"Amsterdam" is about
three friends --
It takes place in the '30s.
It's a beautiful,
beautifully made movie.
I'm so thrilled to
be part of it.
It's about friendship,
and it basically asks
the question about,
"What is your Amsterdam?
What is your favorite time
in your life?"
And we see their favorite time
set against an unbelievably
and historically accurate,
fascinating intrigue.
-I like
"What is your Amsterdam?"
That's pretty great.
-Yeah.
-That sums it all up.
It's perfect.
I want to show everyone a clip.
-Yes, please.
-Mike Myers in "Amsterdam."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Paul Canterbury,
Canterbury Glass.
London, England.
We make the finest prosthetic
glass, industrial glass,
top-secret glass,
military glass,
every kind of glass
except window glass.
Unless, of course,
it's bulletproof.
Have no fear, a friend of
Miss Valerie
is a friend of Paul Canterbury,
who offers you a lifetime supply
of Canterbury Glass eyes.
-Not too bad.
-As you can see,
I've got the same injury as you,
or perhaps you can't see,
due to the fine craftsmanship
of Canterbury Glass.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who else can do that?
Who else can do that?
Mike Myers, everybody!
"Amsterdam" is in theaters now.
Sutton Foster joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.